sur saint quentin en yvelines cette
commune invite les électeurs à se
déplacer pour ce second tour de scrutin
le décret voté précise plusieurs
conditions les premières concerne
l'hygiène le bureau de vote doit prévoir
l'accès à un point d'eau et à du savon
ou mettre à disposition du gel
hydroalcoolique
à noter que le masque est rendue
obligatoire pour les électeurs et les
membres du bureau de vote les
scrutateurs et toute personne contrôlant
le scrutin un masque qui peut être
retiré à la demande d'un membre du
bureau de vote si le contrôle de
l'identité l exige
mais ce masque n'est pas obligatoire
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap
munis d'un certificat médical un
affichage doit être présent à l'entrée
du bureau de vote précisant toutes ces
consignes à une autre mesure spécifique
concerne cette fois les procurations un
mandataire pourra disposer de deux
procurations au lieu d'une
habituellement autorisée par le code
électoral les personnes fragiles malades
ou actuellement en quarantaine peuvent
demander à ce qu'on se déplace chez elle
pour établir ou recevoir le document et
la demande peut aussi être fait par
téléphone courrier ou courriel
il faut alors précisé les raisons qui
empêchent les lecteurs de se déplacer
les procurations pourront être établies
par des officiers ou des agents de
police judiciaire dans des lieux
spécifiques autre que les lieux
habituels qui sont les commissariats et
les gendarmeries les tribunaux la liste
sera elle définit par des arrêtés
préfectoraux et le ministère de
l'intérieur précise qu'une procuration
établie pour le 22 mars est valable pour
le scrutin du 28 juin mais ce n'est pas
le cas pour une procuration réalisé sur
un an et dont la date d'expiration
arrive avant le 28 juin